and another thing by the way and i just
thought this was so
just such a such a wonderful story
last week
alex jones
came out
did a video
where he told his audience
that he was officially endorsing
florida governor ron desantis for
president over donald trump
he not only said
that ron desantis was in jones's words
way better than trump way better than
trump his exact words he also said that
desantis is the kind of guy that uh what
trump should be like
again his exact words what trump should
be like
that was last week
now earlier this week alex jones
realized oh no
i've made a mistake and i've made the
big guy
angry even though as far as i've seen
donald trump has not issued any
statements whatsoever
attacking alex jones for that so i don't
buy for a second alex jones is oh no
trump's angry hey he didn't say anything
didn't seem like he cared
but anyway alex jones comes out this
week
in
what's called an emergency warning
and he says this
not a warning out of any desire to hurt
you mr trump but to save your important
legacy and hopefully ensure you can get
back into the white house coming up in
2024. we know the election was stolen we
know the deep state is trying to set you
up in any way they can we understand you
are a lion surrounded by hyenas so this
is my emergency message to you mr
president to go and actually watch the
first 30 minutes of thursday's show so
you can see what i said in context
the corporate media edited it down to a
30-second clip to make it sound like i'm
only for desantis and that i've
abandoned you that's not true it's the
contrary
right
that that that's totally believable
i mean it's not like you just got popped
for 40 million dollars for lying
so yes we totally believe that the clip
we all saw with our own eyes
heard it with our own ears processed it
with our own brains was totally just
fabricated the media made it up
they deceptively edited it
no
you're on video
literally saying ron desantis is way
better than donald trump
this is what trump should be like
you said that you can look into santa's
eyes here it is um
i don't just watch a man's actions as
christ said judge a tree by its fruit i
can also look in his eyes on hd video
and i see the real sincerity
is that taken out of context
with you talking about how much
you just love ron desantis over donald
trump you also said that you're no
longer you know gonna pig-headedly
that's the word you used support donald
trump
but again this little begging for
forgiveness thing for donald trump i
don't buy it because trump didn't say a
word
i don't know that trump was mad about it
i don't know that trump knew it happened
you know we know trump sits and watches
tv all day long but i don't know that
he's sitting there and watching alex
jones
so i think what happened is that jones
realized he made a lot of his trump
supporting audience mad
so that little emergency warning he
issued that wasn't to make donald trump
happy
that was to make jones's audience happy
by trying to convince them that what he
said last week
totally never happened
i am farron cousins in for david pakman
you can get more from me on youtube at
youtube.com
fair and balanced and youtube.com the
ring of fire i'm on twitter facebook and
instagram at fair and balanced this is
the david pakman show i'm farin cousins
in for david pakman and we'll be right
back
the david pakman show's longest running
sponsor is blinkist the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
each of them down into an explainer you
can read or listen to in 15 minutes
blinkist also condenses episodes of
popular podcasts into 15 minute
explainers i've been using blinkist for
years to supplement the books i read i
love reading i i read all the time but
there's even more books i don't have
time to read and you can often find
those non-fiction books on blinkist and
consume the entire thing in 15 minutes
my favorite new feature on the app is
blinkist connect which lets you share
your blinkist premium account with
someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users i have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to robert greene's the 48 laws of power
the new version robert greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com david
pakman the link is down below